soit ces délits sont à 90 à petit
voilà je peux te dire que tu ressens pas
du tout un cheval la puissance tu n'en
as tu n'en as nina que
l'esa dont tu ne vois pas que ça vaut
voilà ça non mais on a envie d'en non on
ressent
et même les racines à toutes ses dents
jamais à hérisson tu ressembles attia
que tu ressens bientôt non non non non
ah ouais c'est vrai
une toupie qu'un renard
ils sont des cobayes c'est vrai c'est
vrai benhaim bas à la nature semble
alors tu ressembles à une houle ou le
nul ou femme noire non mais lucho
l'autre scénario m'a toujours les nôtres
au plus bas c'est vrai bref mignon mais
pas avant castor
[Applaudissements]
mais non toi tu ressembles plutôt toi je
te vérifier matin sur son blog un
guépard union n'ont jamais inquiété par
les garder chez lui sans rigoler je lui
donne un truc ville il
jetait un truc viril futur chamakh
c'est un truc de fou là alors s éveille
hérisson de minutes
j'adore aller par des pas allant y ait
un poids type de dialoguer pas halal au
porc le léopard et la jaguar
[Rires]
il ya 3 alors c'est qui grimpe à l'arbre
le départ le lot par où le dacquois et
le léopard
lequel plus rapide des
jaguars
qui
l'a dit trop de
succès
[Rires]
j'habite le départ
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du 10 km s'avère même entre eux qui ne
veut
pas dire des conneries
à l'aplomb cinq ans et non pas six
kilomètres quand il a eu du mal à
trouver en tout cas l'on fait des
kilomètres modiano iranienne saluer
nianing chanson reste à faire une chauve
souris
c'est vrai qu'à un stade vide
mais ces victoires nouvelle en hongrie
nien il arrête
toi un gros chien ouais
[Musique]
bah ouais t'as raison que tu ressembles
un panda bon respect voiture n'a pas
annoncé de lass un bond à
des roulades c'est trop mignon
[Rires]
il est arrivé le china matin
mais non
c'est le bouquet
et il est arrivé de chine matin
merde
qu'il me rattrapera pas
djibril wade chose
alors là je m'explique ils sont en train
de chercher le début on l'aura
certainement tout à l'heure sur la
partie belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
je ne sais pas
hors du monde
honteux
à
[Applaudissements]
dépendant
du marché
[Musique]
j'adore les comédies musicales qui te
font une chanson sur mer
je voulais parler un jour derrière passe
me voir à la maison way et quand je
passe bas quand tu passes ta peu tape
taton à terre